it's a great pleasure to have uh john
prychex speaking today
uh in spite of the time changes and
apologize for
california being off from europe or from
the u.s me on from europe
jan's worked extensively in logic and
complexity
especially i would say in bound
arithmetic and profit and propositional
proof complexity uh he's at the charles
u
charles university and he's speaking
today about information efficiency of
proof systems
okay thank you very much thank you for
the
invitation to join your seminar at least
in this way
obviously i am not that qualified to
even make the start of the seminar but
fortunately you waited so thank you very
much uh
once i see that one advantage of being a
speaker is
that i see that there is actually some
audience
in the earlier seminars i attended it
it's very lonely experience because it's
just the speaker the host and
then myself and one can only guess
whether there are some other people or
not so this
is rather nice now
the thing i want to talk about i i
noticed that in
past seminars in this thursday series at
least
people talk often about you know
surveying some
particular method or some development of
the field and so on
and i'm not really going to do that i i
what
i
want to talk about is certain problem
and certain
thinking about a certain problem about
which i
thought from time to time in the last
few months
i started with one problem which i
thought could lead to something new
then i found out that this can be
actually
quite reasonably answered using very
classical parts of
complexity but along the way i stumbled
upon one notion
and one problem about it which i think
would be of
interest and in particular i don't know
how to solve it so
that's what i want to talk about so it's
not really a survey of anything but i
hope
you don't mind so i plan to
spend two or three slides just basic
definition because i'm not sure if
everybody is
good complexity there is and also just
to fix the notation
so the so i'll take the functional
definition of
regrowth version of the propositional
group systems
namely being at the polynomial time
function whose
range is exactly the set of
propositional topologies
in some fixed language and fixed format
for example the morgan formulas or
cna formulas and so on now the
fundamental problem
they they pointed out is whether there
exists a proof system
where the lengths of proofs can be
bounded by a polynomial
so the length of proof function i'll
denote by this symbol at the bottom of
the slide
and it measures how fast or rather how
short those
through system e allows for formulas
and the question they
and the observations they of course
immediately made
was that such a proof system exists if
and only if the class and p is closed
under complementation and therefore
this is kind of a fundamental problem
now one hears
from time to time mentioning of hook's
program to
p versus np i'm not sure if he would be
happy
with people saying that it's a program
but it is a certain approach rather than
solving p versus npu try to solve a
harder problem and p versus 20
but also in a bit different environment
namely in
some logic and logical calculation
system which bring in some
structure which is maybe not available
for algorithms directly
anyway so this is basic one basic two is
that we
we can use this length of proof function
to compare
two proof systems and define not it's
not a partial
ring but it's a quasi ordering so
you say that p is as good as q if it's
at most polynomial is slower than any
then than a proof system q
and the more efficient way of this when
the translation of the proof can be
performed by polynomial time algorithm
so
this quasi ordering by p simulation is
finer than the quasi ordering just by
uh proof length but
in many respects it doesn't really
matter which of
them you have or more precisely when one
shows that something is not
quasi-order then it's usually in the
non-uniform
version the first one and when you say
that something can be simulated then
often it comes with the
effective p simulation okay now
the second fundamental problem is the
optimality problem namely if in this
quasi ordering there are maximal
elements something which would be
optimal with respect to
proof length and this is the last
kind of basic slide this optimality
problem is
really surprising to how many different
areas
of combinatorics and complexity theory
and logic it relates
in quite genuine ways that the existence
of such a
ideal object the optimal system can be
characterized in
completely different language so i
personally i like in some sense moves
the
characterization using the quantitative
gradles theorems
the incomplete test theorem where you
don't just just say that something
is or is not provable but you pay
attention to the length of proofs
in theories okay now there are also some
surprising
result or maybe surprising to when you
see them for the first time
namely that relative to a pure age under
some mild condition on the theory there
is actually such an optimal proof system
and there is also an optimal proof
system among
proof systems where you allow some
advice for example if you allow
advice one bit then among all such proof
systems there is one which is
optimal in this respect so relative to a
theory that means
that you look only at two systems which
are
probably sound in the theory okay
now the problem i
i was interested in is what can one say
about the complexity
or about the optimality of some way to
searching for propositional proofs
so so i'll define a proof search
algorithm
in position logic to be a pair
where p is a propositional group system
a is a deterministic algorithm that
you can require stops on all inputs
that's without
loss of generality with only little
increase in time
and finds p proofs for all tautologies
so using this functional definition
of proof systems it's it's really like
an inverse function to p
so that's quite succinct
presentation of the condition i think
right
so we don't really care what it does on
input which are not technologies
so the informal question is whether
whether there is
actually an optimal way how to
an optimal research algorithm in any
sensible
quasi-ordering of the proof systems now
i'm sure that this
has to occur to everybody and i would
have rather liked
if it turned out that the answer is yes
and p
was some rather weak system you see
something like
little over resolution or resolution
combined with some geometric or
algebraic group system or
some algebraic system something which is
kind of
towards the bottom of the quasi or the
ring of proof systems
because that would in some sense explain
why
why it doesn't make why doesn't help to
search for proofs in strong proof
systems
and it could also
in some sense it would also justify that
looking for algorithms often means
looking for algorithms
aiming at proofs in the same proof
system rather than trying to influence
also the proof system
now i don't know if these remarks or
these informal thoughts make such a
much sense because uh you know i
informally think
about algorithms and how to compare them
without actually knowing much theory how
general algorithms are
to be compared but i'm slightly
suspicious that there is not really that
much fury
so anyway here seems to be a natural
quasi-ordering
by time so similarly as the
quasi-ordering for proof system
here you say that the the proof search
algorithm
ap is say time wise
at least as good as bq if the
time is at most polynomially longer than
the time of b
so note that i i compare proof systems
which may search for proofs in different
group systems that a priori doesn't
that the the quasi-ordering makes
sense in the general sense now there are
there is uh
lemma and the theorem and the lemma is
just the observation that the universal
search
in in the sense of levin gives you
an algorithm which for any fixed proof
system
you you have a time optimal algorithm
among
all roof search algorithms with the same
target proof system so this is
i'm sure that there are sophistic more
sophisticated ways how to
define it so that the time is really the
minimum possible
but basically you for i going from one
to three and so on you
you try lexicographically first i
deterministic algorithms for i
steps and you check whether you have by
any chance found the
p proof of the formula and this this
check is polynomial time because p
is a polynomial time function and so you
can recognize
when one of the algorithm actually found
an answer
and that will be the output of your
algorithm
and it's uh and it has at most
polynomial slowed down over
any algorithm okay so in
in a sense uh if you if you fix
p resolution then there is simply the
best way how to search for resolution
groups
of course it's not the way how any
anybody who actually does the searching
would
hope to do you know to cycle through
other algorithms and
try all of them and so on but
theoretically this
is optimal way how to do it
at least in the sense of this
quasi-ordering
now the teleram i just it's it's also
not difficult but it's
not just the observation that
if you take a proof system which
essentially would just require that
has two properties that it simulates
resolution and then
if you substitute for some variables
constants
then the resulting formula can be proved
essentially by the same
size as the original formula or equals
with the polynomial
slow down okay so under this assumption
the proof system
is p optimal if and only if this
unique proof search algorithm which
which is the optimal
algorithm ap searching for p proofs
is time optimal and now it's among all
through search algorithms
irrespective what is the proof system
they use okay so i interpret this
theorem
as saying that this research problem
which i thought first could lead to some
kind of new
new facet of complexity is actually no
new problem at all
so i will at the end give some reference
to a manuscript to a preprint where i
wrote these things
and this has a couple of proofs one is
using just a classical proof theory
proof complexity another actually uses a
result which we proved with pavel some
30 years ago
which related the existence of the
optimal
uh through system with the existence of
a
with the existence of a deterministic
algorithm computing the characteristic
function of tautologies
in a way that is time optimal on
tautologies
so that can be used to prove this as
well and i'm not going to talk it i
don't think it's really that interesting
now i had these informal doubts
whether this time quasi ordering is
actually
the the right one now namely
i would i am i would be curious if you
can define
some other classic ordering which would
be you know
arguably natural or sensible where the
optimality in this quasi-ordering does
not actually reduce to the
optimality problem for proof systems
now you should always have the time
that if if some algorithm is
at least as good time-wise then it is at
least as good in any quasi-ordering
because so in the language of orderings
it's the finest
one but what if it is not actually
at least as good what if you you have a
algorithm which is a strictly stronger
in this quasi ordering
now this may happen for various kind of
silly reasons for example this ap
can really be just bq except that the
algorithm
a remembers some very uniform set of
formulas
which have long few proofs and for these
specific formulas it remembers it will
declare that the formulas themselves are
proofs for themselves
so p is really just q except that for a
polynomial time set of topologies
it has extra proofs and a
is really just the b except that it
remembers a
sparse and simple set of tautologies
which happen to be hard for a few
so i i don't really know whether it's uh
sensible to claim that the algorithm ap
is actually stronger if
if this is what going on and so i was
thinking if there would be some way
how to compare the algorithms on
tautologies on inputs where they
actually do something
non-trivial whatever that is
now in i had few thoughts like this and
i didn't really get anywhere
except i got it it brought me to the
notion i want to explain in a moment
and i basically convinced myself that
this theorem from the previous slide
is a good answer to the proof search
problem
but or rather like that the
doubts one i express here are you can
probably express
about any class of algorithm searching
solving any type of problems
and i think it's probably very dependent
on the purpose of the algorithms and
what is considered in the community or
in the
class of problems important and whatnot
and so on
and i really didn't wanted to get into
it and i also don't think that one can
actually
prove something general in this respect
but in any case i
i thought first that i should not really
reveal how naive question i have
been posing to myself but then i thought
why not because it leads to something
which is actually a form of
thing so it's not just informal
okay so here is a definition
which is a certain complexity measure of
a proof system
so given a proof system i
you you define a function which to a
tautology
assigns a literal number
and the natural number is this relative
homogeneous complexity
of a proof relative to knowing tau okay
so let me remind the people about this
how this is defined so you look at the
the pairs machine e which computes
w from input u in time at most t
and such a pair machine e
and time e contributes
the length of e and log of plus the log
of time
is its cost and you look at the minimal
cost of such a thing
so this is a version of kolmogorov
complexity
due to 11 time bounded version there are
apparently really very many versions of
of how how the mobile complexity can be
modified
to incorporate time and but
this seems to may be the most sensible
or at least in this context now for
uh tautology of size m and uh
under some mouth condition on on p you
have the following bounds on this
information so it is at most m
and the reason for it is that you need
something like 2 to the m
time to produce by some canonical
algorithm the truth table
proof system
and on the other hand it has to be at
least lock of the minimum size of
approve
because you need the length of a proof
time of the length of a proof to write
it down
and the minimum length is if we assume
that the
through has at least the length of the
formula so it's level bounded by log
okay so this is the range in which this
formula
this value happens now here are two
lemmas which in some sense are
unknown to what i was saying before so
first of all you can use this to
actually lower bound time
any algorithm which will search for a
proof
of of of the tautology we'll have to use
and the calculation is very simple
simply from the definition you have
these inequalities
and therefore the time a has to use is
some constant which depends on a
times 2 to the i so so up to this
multiplicative constant due to the
information complexity of tao
is actually the minimum time which any
algorithm has to use
okay and the second time i kind of
personally call
information automatizability namely that
there is actually an algorithm
which just use essentially the time or
polynomial is slower
and which computes the the proof with
the minimal
content okay so the first thing is just
from this inequality and the second
thing is another version of this
universal search
where you simply search for over all
pairs
algorithm e and time t
up to the cost one two three up to i
and and you eventually find the
the proof of the minimal such
information cost
so but it has the i think it has the
feature which is kind of opposite to
automatizability which doesn't seem to
hold
which never holds so here you can
interpret this as saying that it always
holds in this respect
okay so uh i don't know if there are any
questions
uh i don't mind if people interrupt me
with some questions okay so
what about uh information versus size
so we had this uh this bottom
inequality so uh
if you have a uh
it could happen that this middle
inequality is actually strict and that
the discrepancy between the law of size
and the information might be very big
and so this
this question is whether the information
complexity can give you a better time
level bound for the
algorithm than size normally in
at least i think that usually people
when you have when you are proving that
some procedure
for sub solving requires so much time
then what you are doing is that you are
level bounding the time by the size of
resolution or some other proofs it has
to produce
but in principle it can happen that that
i the information is more than
proportional to look of work of the size
and the question is whether this can
happen and the observation is that this
is actually exactly the characterization
that he is not
automatizable and that fortunately
is almost always the case right i was
rather skeptical
or rather skeptical i simply like on
automatizability not automatizability
but the non-automatizability and the
fact that it gives some kind of positive
face to the fact when
feasible interpolation fails but
now the fact that uh basically nothing
completely is automatizable right except
maybe
one or two exception means that this
discrepancy can actually happen
for essentially any complete
system
so here is a just a calculation how one
can go about
thinking about automatizability in these
terms
so for the purpose of this and next
slide i will
consider that my formula is size m
and i will say that if that some
quantity is small
if it is on the order of log m
and it is large otherwise and the string
is simple if its complexity is small
and complex if its over of complexity is
large
okay now so if you want to witness this
discrepancy between
time and space times and size
sorry information and size then it must
necessarily happen that all proofs are
actually
complex because of this last but one
inequality on this page
and so you want proofs where
you want for the purpose of separating
size from time
from information you want formulas which
have short proofs
but all proofs are complex
now a convenient way how to express this
property
and which holds actually also for which
which
simply makes sense for any formulas is
is to define this red quantity
i t tau and pi
which is it's a quantity which uh
kolmogorov already defined in his you
know
paper in 60s about of course not
time-bounded
complexity but the original one and he
calls this
information that tau conveys about pi
so if you look at it it's simply if this
is small
it means that if you know tau
it doesn't help you much it doesn't give
you much
information about pi namely in order to
produce
pi you still need almost as such
information
as if you are producing pi without any
without knowing any tau
right so this is the quantity
and now uh if we find such formulas
which are actually themselves simple
like the
instances of of some reflection
principle something like that
then in fact automatically this quantity
has to be small
because formula being simple means that
this kt
complexity of tao at the last but one
line on this slide is of the order
all lock o lock and
the then there is some kind of error
terms which are
uh just look size so the error of terms
comes from the fact that
if you have a if you
know what is information cause to
producing tau
and what is information cost of
producing pi
from tao the cost of producing pi is not
just the sum of the previous two
but plus some small log term
size error
so this is computed in more detail in
the paper but
this is what in principle
you would want okay
now here is an example which i take from
our
which i just modified in a sense the and
something we treated with pavel about
extended resolution and rsa
that how to construct formulas which
do have this property explicitly so
you define a formula which says that if
if x is the pre-image of b
in some one-way permutations and the
heartbeat you compute from x
has to be the actual heartbeat
which which is determined by little b
okay so it's easy to see
that this has
[Music]
short proofs because
if you can prove that it is a
permutation that it is
one to one then it's then to prove this
you just need to take the pre-image
plug it in and compute that the bit has
the right value
the heartbeat has the right value and
because you know that it is one to one
the one pre image you found is the only
one there is
and on the other hand if you could if
you could
construct proofs of this if the
information
you needed for that was a little then
then by this
e-automatizability you could construct
these proofs in
polynomial or polynomial time
and that would simply allow you to
compute what the heart that is in
polynomial time
because you would know whether or not
this formula is a tautology or not
and so assuming that it is a one-way
permutation and that
in your proof system you can prove that
it is one way then
this gives you an example of
formulas for which that inequality
is satisfied okay
so
other proofs for other proof systems can
lead to some other examples
now one thing is that i am not quite
happy with this
example and these arguments because the
if you want to separate size from
information you
necessarily have to prove that p is
different from np because
it basically means that there is some
short object
namely the proof which is easy to
recognize
namely by the proof system but it's not
easy to find it
because the information required is
bigger than
and so if you have such examples their
analysis and the proof
have to use some conjectures which
implies that p different from mp so
in the idle case p is different from np
itself
like in the work of albert and moritz
and in some other cases some other
conditions
but i would like if one could simply
treat
this information measure in the same
ways as the size measure namely
for individual formulas you see so we
have a
lower bound say for pigeonhole principle
in some proof systems and of course this
rubber bound has some
constant in it and so you can express it
that for
n the size of something has to be 2 to
the n to 1 over 3 or whatever
but in principle you don't have to it
doesn't matter that the formula is a
part of some ambient uniform sequence
you simply have one
pigeonhole principle formula for one
n and you do you apply the method random
restrictions or whatever
and then the adversary argument against
the resulting simplified group or some
other method
and you come up with a number and it
just does not depend
on whether you consider the formula of
being part of some ambient
sequence so i asked marcel for for what
do what do we actually use lower bound
for
in in proof system so one thing is of
course that we would like to
show that nothing is p bounded and so
eventually showing this way that np is
different from coin
other things are the the topic which is
probably
closest to hearts of the program
participants namely that
you can use it to time lover bound sub
algorithms which are simulated by the
proof systems
so in particular if the proof system
gets a little bit stronger
all those algorithms whose soundness can
be proved there
then the time level bound will follow so
in some sense you can you
look at it that you are proving
instances of p different from np
namely you are ruling out certain
classes of sub algorithms
and finally the and at least i think
quite importantly there are also
independence results for the bounded
arithmetic theories attached to b and in
particular
you showed that p is different from np
is consistent with this theory
now i i'm not sure if logic is
something you know it doesn't seem to be
part of your proof complexity boot camp
so i don't really want to talk about
this three but
at least this last line that you are
showing certain consistency
this i think of interest now the point
is
that in fact to do this you don't need
size level bounds
information lower bounds are just as
good
so assume i actually managed to prove
what corresponds to super polynomial
size of a balance namely i proved that i
will have some
infinite class of formulas or i can
produce
arbitrarily large formula tau such that
its information efficiency function is
is more it cannot be bounded by constant
times of
size now if you have this then it is
essentially as good as having super
polynomial size level bound because it
in the first case it doesn't you know if
you would have that for all proof
systems
it would not imply that mp is different
from coin p but it would apply
that either it isn't different or p is
different from np and we are happy with
that right
it also implies time level bounds for
sub algorithms
that was dilemma one stated before and
it also implies the independence results
because the independence results are
obtained by
propositional translations the argument
is that if something has a proof
then in fact sorry first order proof
then its propositional translation have
shown proofs and so
our bounds gives you independence but
in fact these propositional translations
are performed by polynomial time
algorithms often and so
it's it's not about existence of short
rules but it's actually how you can
construct them so information is just as
useful
and so it led me to the following
problem which i think
is is a sensible problem to at least
understand whether
it's unbelievable or not and possibly
solve it namely
prove such lower bounds but
unconditionally
give examples of formula style and prove
unconditional lower bounds of this form
for the information efficiency
and ideally for a proof system for which
we have no super polynomial size or
other bonds
now if we don't manage this then at
least prove such size
our bounds for proof system which we you
know seem to know a lot about
resolution or constant afraid or
whatever
but for formulas for which you do not
have size lower bounds
so prove simply this information lower
bound instead
okay and one should keep in mind that
you you should
rather expect that the e heart
information heart formula has the
formulas which would witness this
inequality should have long proofs
because
if you also manage to find them such
that they have short proofs then you are
actually proving that p is different
from np
and therefore you are likely to have to
use some hypothesis in the truth
therefore if you want unconditional
overbound one should really aim at
formulas which have long proofs but the
point is that i want the information
about
not to be derived from the size of the
proofs but
by some other means okay
now let me give just two candidates the
the first candidates the uniform
which might be just reflection formulas
for
some proof system which we think should
be stronger than p
now it it would have the advantage that
these formulas are
simple in the chroma world of sense
their complexity is about log m
because they are efficiently produced
once you are given the length m
but on the other hand they are just too
general everything can be somehow
reduced to them
and so it's doubtful whether one
can avoid using some hypothesis
okay now also maybe one one should
consider reflection formulas not with
respect to
not saying that proofs of size at most
m are sound but that proves whose
complexity is say atmosphere
sound um well
i don't know i just wanted to mention
that this is a class of
uniform formulas and therefore simple in
the chromograph sense which could be
the the second set of non-uniform
candidates are
these formulas where you take a function
which
takes input with n bits and produces
more bits
and therefore most m bit strings will
not be in the range of
of the function and the formula says
exactly this that b is not in the range
of the function
so here the y variables are
some kind of auxiliary variables that
help you to write down the computation
and
a simple observation is that if these
actually absolute random generators and
in fact
you have the lower bound but
this is an observation of no help to the
problem because you are of course not
allowed to use this hypothesis
that something is purely random so one
should look at specific functions which
were
considered for the purpose of these tau
formulas having long proofs
and cases where we were not able to
prove it and try to
prove it at least for the information so
i'm hoping that this might stimulate
some kind of
rubber bound method which would be
different
okay so i'm to the last one slide i just
wanted to
mention that there are quite a few
topics improve complexity which i think
are somehow related namely that they
more or less explicitly or implicitly
contain
some uh compression or decompression
functions simply some proofs which are
somehow compressed or
in the argument you use some compression
for
for proofs or formulas and so on so some
of this is treated in the paper but
not all of them so anyway i'm running
out of time so this is the last slide so
i just want to point
out that i have a preliminary version of
a draft of this stuff
on my web page and not everything which
is which i mentioned today is there
but there or to be some revision soon
and i have mentioned quite a few through
complexity results and
if you want to you know find the
background you can maybe find it in this
book in with in the index there
okay so thank you very much for
attention and
uh sorry again to be one hour late
thank you very much for the talk uh i'll
clap on everybody's behalf since we
can't clap in the ordinary sense
uh we have some time for questions and
uh please either
just break in and speak out or type into
the chat window
or the q a window um
so maybe while people are thinking about
questions or something like that i could
ask something though
uh about somewhere back about five or
six slides you said that
in in that lower bounds on information
complexity were just as useful
uh and i was just wondering could you so
i guess
you didn't mention i think the previous
slide mentioned np not equal to co mp is
one of the
consequences could that also follow from
yeah
well what follows here is that
you either show that the proof system is
not p
bounded and maybe none of them are and
then it does
but if it is p bounded and you have the
lover bound then you are showing that p
is different from np
so so so this is uh just as good
means that in this first case i would
have to compromise a little bit
and rather than getting this inequality
one would get that p is different from
np
and and in items two and three i think
you don't have to compromise at all
and so i guess that means that we it's
going to be extremely difficult to find
unconditional lower bounds on
information complexity
well yes but uh it will be it would be
but it cannot be more difficult than for
size
right and so therefore it could be
doable
for those proof systems for which we do
not have size
unconditional size lower bounds or
for the proof systems where we do have
such size our bounds but not
for formulas you know for some formulas
you would want them but you do not have
the lower bounds so maybe one could at
least get
this information motherboard i don't
know i mean
this um i i think
[Music]
i think that simply the setup of this or
this this
measure is somehow more
first of all you have this lemma 2 which
i call information automatizability and
once you have information
automatizability you of course have
something like information interpolation
in some sense and if you formulate it in
just the most straightforward way it's
not very helpful but there might be some
more sophisticated ways how to
formulate it so there might be a way how
to use this measure to actually extract
from proof
some kind of other computational
information when it is extracted by
feasible interpolation
that's what i would be interested in
more but
you know rather than saying this big
problem i think that this
this problem is simply
well defined and challenging i think at
least
okay good i have a question
so can you remind us
how the existence of an optimal proof
system affects the theory
you started with that but i i mean the
concepts
[Music]
so do you mean the thing which i say
here at the bottom or
well that would be the second question
but the question suppose there is an
optimal proof system what
does it make to the theory i mean does
it trivialize or the contrary
well no you mean the theory attached to
it
no no no i mean the theory of
information complexity the one you're
introducing
oh i see so uh no i mean it would show
that the information efficiency function
is
optimal for this p optimal proof system
because the p
optimality okay so that's uh
so okay so so i can order to prove
systems p
and q by saying that the information
efficiency function
for p is not bigger than q
up to a multiplicative constant okay
then this is a quasi ordering
and it is coarser than the p of p
simulation so if you would have a
p optimal proof system its information
efficiency would be in a sense optimal
in the sense that no proof system can
have
better information efficiency function
except multiplying by a constant
yeah so that's
okay i mean i i'm also wondering whether
it
whether actually one could define this
function
[Music]
whether there is some sensible limit of
this which does not depend on the proof
system at all
i mean of course one can define
something like the kolmogorov version of
it where you would take
the size of the algorithm computing p
into account but
you know it doesn't i i haven't found
some kind of sensible question or
statement about it to
make such a definition okay
and now in the last slide or one to last
slide you mentioned
proof systems with advice for which yeah
this is uh yes you proved the existing
so they are defined so in ordinary proof
system it doesn't matter whether you
take this relational definition or
functional for proof systems with the
devices
it's better to take the functional
definition and the proof system simply
may use some advice which depends on the
length of proof
and what we prove with steve cook is
that there is actually a proof system
with
one bit of advice which simulates
uh which piece simulates all classical
cracker-proof systems
and simulates all proof systems with
lock and bits of advice
and the simulating function would use
also advice
okay but uh so what do you get here
now you can take this so i take this
through system with one bit of advice
which polynomially simulates all
classical ones
and so you would hope that the proof
search algorithm for
it is actually something which is you
know better than any classical one
but unfortunately the this well
fortunately are unfortunately i don't
know but
this universal search will actually
result in
in a
yeah so ah do you hear me
uh what happens with the algorithm the
the search yeah so
so when you simply do this uh search for
you know construction of the optima
algorithm you are actually circling over
proof search algorithms with different
proof systems and the advices these
proof system issues would accumulate
so you would end up with a you know
polynomial time
non-uniform proof search algorithm
and so what i mean
okay yeah okay i mean yeah so what
okay all right
can i say something yes
hi john it was a great talk um thank you
very much
they take a while to digest it i like
that i automatic
the lingo with the eye in front but i
have a more serious question
so um just a little curious how you came
up with this
notion of information um i mean
right you get some information about you
wanted to be instant specific
but yeah if you could say something
about why other measures like
well yeah so this is what i was
trying to which i was first not sure
whether i should mention
these very naive considerations that one
should
one should compare algorithms where they
are actually doing something
you know to own instances and then
simply some line of thought
led to this notion i
actually probably it was a random
thought
but yeah so but i think it's um you know
it's it's like with kolmogorov
complexity of course it's not
substantially different than from
talking about
algorithms but it gives you a certain
perspective different perspective on
some problems and especially
the fact that you can look at things
individually rather than
having them as part of some ambient
sequence
and whether or not this will help to
anything
i don't really know but i i think that
to find out
a good problem is the problem which i
formulated
at the end
yeah i wonder if the other measures
could be interesting too maybe for
random
formulas or for distributional
settings yeah well um
i i yeah
i don't know i mean
i think that people who actually work
with such algorithms they can't really
agree on on which to test them right
it's kind of very ad hoc and it's not
really mathematically principle
theory behind the testing of or
comparing two algorithms it's
some kind of competition and the experts
agree that it's fair
try it on these examples but there
doesn't seem to be some theory behind it
and
i think that uh it probably depends on
the purpose for which these algorithms
are used and in the environment
type of problems they get and so on
okay any other questions or discussion
or comments
well i guess we'll we'll end up here
thank thank you again and also
thank you and i apologize again for
being so late
so and as a reminder the gather town
link is available in the chat window
if people want to come afterwards and
meet up there
so uh i hope to see some of you there
bye-bye